[Musique]
oui ouais j'habitais
ici, ne veux-tu pas entrer c'est le moins que je puisse
faire c'est comme si tu te souvenais plus propre ouais
eh bien tu te sens libre de regarder autour pendant que
je fais bouillir l'eau
tes cheveux sont le feu de l'hiver
[Musique]
voilà une musique géniale, je m'excuse, il fait tellement chaud ici à
cette période de l'année, c'est bien, mais avez-vous l'
impression que vous pourriez à peu près mourir, mais
vous savez ce qu'ils disent à propos des produits laitiers hmm
personne qui meurt ici ne meurt vraiment
mais dites-moi  comment est-ce que c'est de retour à
Derry c'est étrange oh mon dieu
j'avais des cookies dans le four avant que
tu viennes Steve juste là
je ne devrais pas imposer je vais non j'insiste
nous les photos sont adorables mademoiselle Kirsch sont-
elles ta famille ma  père est venu dans ce
pays avec 14 $ en poche qu'a-t-
il fait mrs.  Kirsch mon père a rejoint le
cirque
j'ai toujours été la petite fille de papa et
toi tu es toujours sa petite fille
Beverly es-
tu  ensemble
[Musique]
bonjour